الصين هاجس الدول الغربيه والعنصر الرئيسي
في قممها السياسيه وهذا حال قمه السبع في
هيروشيما
التحركات الصينيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
ومحاولتها فرض السيطرتها على هذا الممر
البحري من خلال ضم جزر تطالب بها دول جنوب
شرق اسيا اضافه الى مناوراتها العسكريه
التي تقترب من شواطئ تايوان مره بعد
الاخرى هي مصدر قلق لدول المجموعه وعلى
راسها امريكا التي تدعم مانيلا عسكريا
لتامين حدودها
اما على المستوى الاقتصادي في الاشهر التي
سبقت القمه قامت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي واليابان
بتنسيق سياسه تستبعد الفصل الكامل للتجاره
مع بكين اكبر اقتصاد في اسيا فالصين هي
الشريك الاقتصادي الاول لليابان والاتحاد
الاوروبي والثالث للولايات المتحده بعد
كندا والمكسيك ولهذا يصعب القطع الكامل
معها ولكن يبقى من غير الواضح الى اي مدى
قد تكون اليابان والاوروبيون على استعداد
لاتخاذ اجراءات يمكن ان تستفز بكين نظرا
لما يمكن ان تتخذه هذه الاخيره من اجراءات
انتقاميه
الصين سبقت قمه السبع ونظمت قمه استضافت
فيها كازاخستان وقرغيزيستان وطاجيكستان
وكذلك تركمانستان واوزباكستان وهذا
استمرار في مسعا لتوسيع نطاق تاثيرها
اسيويا بعيدا عن الضغوطات الغربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات